dieser Spruch von den blühenden
Landschaften ich weiß gar nicht ob junge
das heute noch wissen aber dieses
Versprechen diese Suggestion der Westen
ist da und jetzt bekommt er blühende
Landschaften transportiert letzten Endes
ja auch das Klischee vorher habt ihr in
Schutt und Asche gelegen ja und
natürlich war die Wirtschaft am Ende
natürlich hat es Zerfall gegeben
natürlich hat es danach eine
Erfolgsgeschichte von Erneuerung von
Modernisierung von teilweise besserer
Infrastruktur gegeben aber daneben neben
dieser Erfolgsgeschichte existiert eben
auch ein Gefühl bei vielen älteren
ostdeutschen würde ich sagen ich glaube
bei den Jüngeren hat es sich schon
anders ausgeprägt das ist nicht mehr das
gleiche dass das nicht gewollt gewesen
ist das ist nur als Kostenfaktor ja
bisschen dazu dass lange Zeit verbreitet
wurde dass die Westdeutschen
Solidaritätszuschlag bezahlen und damit
den Aufbau ist finanziert haben
wurde gerne weggelassen oder auch
bewusst ignoriert ja wir haben es nie
geschafft eine gemeinsame
Erfolgsgeschichte daraus zu machen
das ist der Punkt und das ist einfach
verdammt schade weil es so viel verloren
ist total interessant ich noch mal die
Frage auch mit Blick auf die AFD über
kurz sprechen müssen ähm ich
wer kauft vor allen Dingen dieses Buch
sind es sehr junge Menschen ich habe das
Gefühl ich schaue sehr sozusagen auf
diese doch große Erfolgsgeschichte ich
habe das vorhin auch mal kurz so
skizziert die Technologien der Zukunft
und so weiter ich habe über die Straßen
gesprochen vieles mehr und ich freue
mich darüber ich finde das gut das ist
das gibt und ich habe das Gefühl jüngere
vor allem auch ostdeutsche empfinden das
so und wenn wir zum Beispiel auch unsere
Situation hierher nehmen in unserer
Redaktion niemand würde jemanden
deswegen nicht einstellen weil aus
Ostdeutschland kommt das ist albern wir
fragen ja gar nicht danach sind kein
Menschen es wird sich allerdings auch
keiner
das ist das andere Thema also das ist
Teil des Problems was sie zum Schluss
angesprochen haben das ist sozusagen
noch mal ein eigenes Feld erstens würde
ich sagen es gibt auch in Hamburg in
München schöne Straßen und schöne Häuser
also das war man nicht vergessen
ganz vorher schon und man man
könne dass ich lange in Köln gelebt das
war immer ich freue mich für jeden dem
es gut geht ja ich auch ja
sie haben danach den Verkaufszahlen
gefragt also ich es ist schon so dass
das Buch zu 70 75 % im Osten gekauft
wird interessant und so 20 25 % im
besten vielleicht sind sie im Westen
dann 24% von den ehemaligen ostdeutschen
die darüber gegangen sind das heißt ich
habe nicht ähm was die Altersstruktur
angeht da kann ich im Blick auf den
verkaufen nicht sagen es ist sicher so
das merke ich auch an der Resonanz genau
komme dass die die vor 1980 geboren
wurden im Buch tendenziell eher
zustimmen und dass die die Jünger sehen
also die nach 1980 geboren den in Teilen
im Buch kritischer gegenüber stehen
nicht alle natürlich weil sich ja die
benachteiligungsstrukturen nicht einfach
dann auflösen sondern die sind auch für
die jungen Leute ganz massiv gegeben
aber da gibt es schon generationelle
Unterschiede das ist so ganz sicher und
was sozusagen das Agieren der jüngeren
einen betrifft sie haben ja auch davon
gesprochen dass die anders damit umgehen
da würde ich sagen müsste man fragen ob
das nicht schon selber ein diskursiver
Effekt der zur Richtung des Ostens ist
also wenn immer gesagt wird ihr seid
Osten ihr seid so und so und so und dann
sagen die irgendwann gut dann sind wir
eben Osten und das ist cool
wenn du ständig zu hören kriegst du bist
ein NAZI ja dann ist der Reflex
irgendwann so eine Bockigkeit die sagt
na gut dann gebe ich dir jetzt auch den
Nazis auch wenn ich das möglicherweise
gar nicht bin eine Sache noch im
Zusammenhang sie Zitat ich sehe einen
unglaublichen Widerwillen des Westens
auf uns zuzugehen
interessant das betrifft ja sogar ihre
eigene Partei also die West deutschen
Grünen wollten von den ostdeutschen
Umweltschützern erstmal nichts wissen
naja ich würde sagen dass ich das durch
die gesamte Gesellschaft zieht natürlich
da nehme ich meine Partei überhaupt
nicht aus oder auch das
Bildungsbürgertum man kann da glaube ich
keine Gruppe von ausnehmen aber wir
haben ja in der Mitte der 90er Jahre
eine sehr gezielte politische
Entscheidung getroffen und die
Vereinigung zwischen diesen beiden
Gruppierungen vollzogen die sich bis
heute durch den Namen auch ausdrückt der
übrigens ja für Werbekampagnen für
Wahlkämpfe unglaublich sperrig ist passt
auf keinen Plakat vernünftig drauf
deshalb hat immer wieder Diskussionen
gegeben ob das klug ist und wir haben
das belassen wir sagen das ist unsere
Geschichte und wir tragen die sehr
selbstbewusst nach außen wir hatten eine
ich finde wirklich sehr sehr
interessante Gedenkveranstaltung in
diesem Jahr dazu und dass da trotzdem
auch in meiner Partei nicht alles gut
gelaufen ist das können sie annehmen ja
es ist interessant AFD Oschmann
sie sagen auch das so eine Zuschreibung
da sind jetzt diese ganzen Nazis und
deswegen kann man da auch gar nicht mehr
sein der Ossi ist ein Nazi und sagt das
regt die Leute unfassbar auf ich kann
das verstehen die Frage ist ist das
falsch und wenn es falsch ist warum ist
es falsch also zunächst würde ich dafür
plädieren die AFD als
gesamtgesellschaftliches als
gesamtdeutsches Problem zu sehen man
sieht ja auch wie die
Werte in den westlichen Bundesländern
wachsen aber in den fünf neuen Ländern
umsetzen mal sozusagen
Widerspruch Widerspruch wir hatten
bereits vor ich glaube acht Jahren in
Baden-Württemberg eine Wahl wo die bei
16 Prozent sagen wir hatten mehrere
zweistellige Wahlergebnisse für die AFD
mehrere Jahre 30 wir sind in Sachsen bei
über 30 stärkste Kraft das ist schon
eine andere Dimension Baden-Württemberg
16 Prozent ist jetzt nicht nicht
und viele der AFD Funktionäre kommen aus
das eine Gesellschaft die eine solche
transformationserfahrung eine solche
umbrucherfahrung hatte von dermagogen
möglicherweise leichter beeinflusst
werden kann als eine die über viele
Jahrzehnte stabil gewachsen ist sich
entwickeln konnte aus sich heraus dass
liegt glaube ich auf der Hand also ich
bin mir nicht sicher ob die 16 Prozent
in Baden-Württemberg irgendwie harmloser
sind als 20 in Thüringen nein aber 30 in
Thüringen habe ich gesagt und über 30
und in Sachsen ähnliche Werte also will
jetzt auch gar nicht darüber mit ihnen
streiten ich will nur sagen aber das ist
ein wichtiger Punkt
in Bayern haben die auch 16 15 16 %
obwohl es da die Freien Wähler und
obwohl CSU gibt und ich bin ziemlich
sicher
ist keine rechtsradikale Bahn nein
aber natürlich sind da Argumentationen
zu beobachten wenn sie anfangen sehen
und auch Herrn Söder wo man sagen würde
so weit von der AFD ist es nicht
entfernt und wenn man sagen würde die
gäbs nicht sondern es gibt als übliche
Parteienspektrum dann würde ich sagen
hätte Bayern durchaus afd-werte wie in
Thüringen und Sachsen nämlich um die 30
Prozent würde ich ziemlich sicher sein
dass es so wäre aber natürlich wird hier
mit doppelten Standards gearbeitet das
sieht man unter anderem daran dass
jemand bhanger in der Position bleiben
kann in der gewesen ist trotz dieser
Affäre das wären für ein Politiker aus
dem Osten völlig undenkbar gewesen
dessen politisches Leben wäre nach so
einer Affäre beendet gewesen sie
sicher da bin ich sicher ein
ostpolitiker bei dem ein antisemitisches
Flugblatt gefunden worden wäre dessen
politisches da sein wäre beendet gewesen
aber sagt ich habe das nicht geschrieben
oder Bruder sagt ich habe es geschrieben
und wo wir als als Medien nicht den
Nachweis erbringen konnten dass das
wirklich selber geschrieben hat so
würde weil der Osten ganz anders
gemessen und bemessen wird und bewertet
wird weil die Standards andere sind im
Blick auf den Osten das ist einfach so
im öffentlichen Raum finde ich finde ich
eine interessante These ich ich finde
auch dass man nee tut mir leid sie haben
gerade gesagt wir müssen da genau sein
die AFD ist nicht die CSU es tut mir
leid nein das habe ich auch nicht gesagt
aber sie sagen da gibt's so Äußerungen
die gehen so in die Richtung wenn sie
sagen Söder vor ein paar Jahren würde
ich sagen da gab's mal so
Begrifflichkeiten
dann haben sie einen Punkt aber Söder
aktuell nichts gar nichts
gut er sieht ja dann auch was es
bedeutet dann einmal irgendwie zu
produzieren oder eben nicht zu
protestieren ja der hat ja da sozusagen
rechts von sich noch eine Partei die
noch mal zwischen der CSU und der AFD
steht also ich gehe zu das ist jetzt
relativ spekulativ das ist zugestanden
und trotzdem finde ich dass man solche
Dinge nicht einfach außer Acht lassen
kann aber trotzdem die Genauigkeit also
diese diese diese diese harte zuspitzt
und diese Joachim Gauck gefällt mir auch
ein sie sagen Jochen mit dem rechnen sie
auch richtig hart ab und sagen der redet
von Dunkeldeutschland
naja hat auch sich diesen Begriff zu
eigen gemacht aber nochmal in welchem
Zusammenhang das habe ich nicht mehr
genau im Kopf aber sehr entschuldigt sie
sind nicht Naturwissenschaftler und kein
Politikberater oder politischer
machen ja es geht einfach darum dass es
sich das ist ja wohl unbestritten dass
er sich dieses Begriffe es bedient hat
und das findest das stimmt aber sie
kennen den Zusammenhang nicht ich habe
ihn jetzt nicht erinnerlich ich habe ihn
auf jeden Fall mal mir genauer angesehen
aber ich habe ihn jetzt nicht präsent
aber sie benutzen sie benutzt ihn als
harten Vorwurf gehen und sagen da
benutzt ein ein er sagt immer redet
immer von Ossis und es ist deswegen sage
ich jetzt auch mal und mit seiner
Sprache zu bleiben einziehen die Familie
die aussieht sozusagen als
Dunkeldeutschland das ist der Vorwurf
den sie machen das ist der Vorwurf das
ist nicht auf diese Weise davon
distanziert
sie kennen aber den Kontext nicht im
Moment habe ich mich präsent aber sie
haben noch viel gebucht dafür
recherchiert ja aber das Buch habe ich
vor einem Jahr geschrieben und es ist
manchmal so dass man nicht alles präsent
ist aber gerade mal so harten Vorwürfen
und ist jetzt nicht irgendjemand muss
man doch den kommentieren nur für mich
kommt hier tatsächlich nur auf die
Tatsache der Gott mal selber einen dass
er sich diesen Begriff zu eigen gemacht
hat um diesen historisch geographischen
Raum haben und das finde ich
problematisch nach wie vor aber es ist
das es ist das
krasse Gegenteil davon gemeint gut
erklären Sie mich das nochmal angesehen
er hat er hat in hier nach einem Besuch
ne nach Flüchtlingsunterkunft in Berlin
hat er folgendes gesagt die vielen
Freiwilligen die zeigen wollen es gibt
ein helles Deutschland dass ich hier
Leuchten darstellt gegenüber dem Dunkel
Deutschland dass wir empfinden wenn wir
von Attacken auf Asylbewerber
Unterkünfte oder fremdenfeindliche
Aktionen gegen Menschen hören damit es
nicht aus Deutschland so ist es aber im
öffentlichen Raum doch im Wesentlichen
rekrutiert worden er hat es nicht so
gemeint ganz offensichtlich er redet von
ganz Deutschland
ich verstehe was sie meinen der Begriff
Dunkeldeutschland bezog sich hat ja
historisch auch eine Herkunft wenig
Straßenbeleuchtung und sowas interessant
diesen und dann sehr bösartig irgendwann
interpretiert aber er bezieht ihn nicht
darauf in keinster Weise können wir uns
darauf verständigen dass wir in
Ostdeutschland
über lange Zeit ein krasses Problem mit
Rechtsextremismus gehabt haben dass ich
von dem im Westen unterschieden hat wenn
ich auf die 90er Jahre auf die früh 90er
Jahre auf die vielen mordart verschaue
das hatte was mit Ostdeutschland zu tun
das hatte was mit Gewalttaten zu tun die
dort stattgefunden haben wir haben ein
gesamtdeutsches Problem mit
Rechtsextremismus mit der AFD als einer
Partei wo man Herrn höcke gerichtsfest
als Faschisten bezeichnen darf und das
ist unser Kernproblem das vom
Rechtsextremismus von der AFD Demokratie
insgesamt angegriffen wird in Frage
gestellt wird die Grundfesten unseres
Staates in Frage gestellt werden und
dass das schon lange kein
ost-west-probleme ist sondern eins dass
wir miteinander haben teilen dass wir
miteinander bearbeiten sollten und dass
diejenigen die in einer solchen Phase wo
wir riesengroße Probleme haben Krisen
haben auf dem ganzen Globus sich dann im
Rechtspopulismus bedienen um Wahlerfolge
zu erzielen und das meinte glaube ich an
Söder und Herrn Aiwanger auch Herr März
ganz gezielt Klischees bedienen wo die
Grenzen zum rechten Rand langsam aber
sicher fließend werden und dass das in
unserer Gesellschaft im Moment etwas
macht was wir glaube ich alle hier als
extrem problematisch oder sogar
gefährlich einstellen
mit der mit der Sprache
also auch jetzt wenn man jemanden wie
Gauck zum Beispiel dann sowas
unterstellt
wenn Sie sich ansehen wie das rezipiert
worden ist dann ist genau diese Linie
doch gezogen
funktioniert ja nicht so der öffentliche
Raum funktioniert ja so dass er sie
haben es ja genauso rezipiert das ist
das ist tatsächlich das was ich Ihnen an
dem Punkt
aber das werfe ich Ihnen vor das finde
ich nicht in Ordnung
[Musik]
das gerade sieht das machen ihn hört man
zu sie verkaufen 100.000 Bücher und die
Leute lesen das und sagen ach guck mal
der Gauck hat in uns aussieht als dunkel
Deutschland die Familie hatte aber nicht
[Musik]
ich hätte trotzdem einen Interesse daran
lieber über das gravierende Problem von
Rechtsextremismus zu reden
deutlich problematischere ich weiß nicht
ob ihnen da jetzt eine Unklarheiten
Fehler unterlaufen ist dass das keine
Ärger jetzt nicht beurteilen aber was
doch Fakt ist ist dass wir ein Problem
haben mit Rechtsextremismus das lange
vernachlässigt worden ist in
Ostdeutschland bis hin zum
Ministerpräsidenten damals der sagte
Sachsen hat nie ein Problem mit
Rechtsextremismus
meine ich das lange Zeit ne also kein
ostdeutscher glaube ich das lange Zeit
ignoriert worden ist vernachlässigt
worden ist und das heute und hier und im
jetzt ein riesengroßes Problem für uns
darstellt in Zeiten wie gesagt so
Politik mit wirklich großen real
existierenden Problemen muss letzte
Frage dazu weil uns leider die Zeit
davon läuft ja auch schon aber wir
sollten das nochmal vertiefen
interessante darüber nachzudenken
warum fällt der Import West
Björn höcke und das Wasser sagt
in Ostdeutschland auf dermaßen
fruchtbaren Boden warum ist das so
also es hat natürlich als staatsreson in
der DDR den Antifaschismus gegeben das
sei der erste an die faschistische Staat
und die Rechen Tendenzen und die Rechten
Entwicklung dieser Osten genauso gegeben
hat sind und dann Deckel gehalten worden
die sind tabuisiert worden und man hat
ja auch gesehen wie in den 80er Jahren
zunehmend insbesondere dann auch Kinder
von sedkadern sich ganz nach rechts
bewegt haben weil sie gesehen haben wie
hoch das provokationspotenzial ist
sozusagen das ganze Gegenteil zu machen
und zu behaupten und das ist natürlich
in den 90er Jahren aufgebrochen wenn sie
mit jüngeren reden also Leuten die
Kinder und Jugendliche waren in den
90ern die sagen man konnte entweder
links oder rechts sein aber nichts
dazwischen ja das ist sozusagen eine
ganz harte polarisierte Polarisierung
und die haben das natürlich auch als
Brutalisierung ihres Alltags erlebt und
aus verschiedenen Gründen weil unter
anderem die Eltern sich um sich selber
kümmern müssen
und mussten man spricht auch von der
Generation der unberatung das heißt es
hat eine Radikalisierung stattgefunden
und das Herr höcke in Thüringen Erfolg
hat ja das hat in erster Linie damit zu
tun dass er in Thüringen agiert und
nicht in Niedersachsen oder in
Schleswig-Holstein sondern das ganz
gezielt diese Länder ausgesucht worden
sind mit der schwierigen
umbrucherfahrung mit Verwerfungen auf
der sozialen Ebene auf der ökonomischen
Ebene
ganz gezielt versucht hat in diesen
Ländern Fuß zu fassen und Menschen zu
instrumentalisieren die schwere Jahre
hinter sich gehabt haben deswegen frage
ich ja danach verstehen Punkt ist
natürlich jetzt noch gekommen ja das
natürlich ist ein braunen Boden im Osten
auch gegeben hat und die Leute die die
höcke auf dem braunen Boden des Westens
gewachsen sind die sind ja gezielt in
Osten gegangen um diesen braunen Boden
mobilisieren und natürlich um da auch
Infrastrukturen aufzubauen es gab ja das
beschreibe ich ja im Buch auch gezielt
von den Rechten von der NPD in Bayern
Plan Sachsen zu unterwandern auch
Michael Kraske der Journalisten
Publizist hat es ausführlich beschrieben
und wie sehr da auch die Staatsorgane
versagt haben Verfassungsschutz
sächsische Regierung mit
Ministerpräsident Biedenkopf es ist über
Jahre hinweg davon die Rede gewesen
Sachsen sei auf dem rechten Auge blind
und nie hat sich daran etwas geändert
auf institutioneller Seite es hat
sozusagen dann ein großes
institutionelles Versagen gegeben so
dass es auch wachsen konnte jemand wie
Hoffmann also der Kopf der
Wehrsportgruppe Hoffmann der eine
Bundesrepublik im Knast gesessen hat ist
nach 1990 in den Osten gegangen und hat
beispielsweise in Carla südlich von Jena
systematisch Wohnungen und Häuser
aufgekauft dann hat er sozusagen seine
rechten Netzwerke aufgebaut und der
Verfassungsschutz hat Anfang des Jahres
darauf hingewiesen ein wie großes
Problem es ist es immer mehr Rechte in
den Osten ziehen unter anderem weil sie
da stärker unter dem Radar agieren
können es gibt nicht so viel
Aufmerksamkeit dafür es gibt den Frauen
Boden sie können weniger beachte
ihre Arbeit und ihrem Aufbau dieser
Netzwerke nachgehen und das hat doch in
gewisser Weise da starke und feste
Strukturen inzwischen etablieren die
jetzt zum riesigen Problem geworden sind
weil man nicht früh genug gesehen hat
dass man dagegen vorgehen muss und wenn
jetzt die Bundesregierung beschließt
Gelder in der politischen Bildung zu
streichen wenn ich das richtig sehe dann
halte ich das für eine Katastrophe also
diese das die Gelder werden im
notwendigen Umfang zur Verfügung stehen
aber mich stört an der Diskussion die
wir jetzt hier gerade nehmen dass wir
wieder dabei sind dass das Problem
Rechtsextremismus aus deutsch ist und
das ist es nicht und ich finde dass
diese aus Deutschland
mit mir ist wichtig dass die Debatte
über Ostdeutschland auch von unserer
Seite nicht in die Ecke führt das
Rechtsextremismus prima gemacht ist aber
wir reden über Ostdeutschland über
Rechtsextremismus und ich finde das
wirklich klar sein muss was für eine
riesen Bedrohung das inzwischen ist für
die Ökonomie in diesem Land für Menschen
in diesem Land sie bedroht werden und
dass wir das in allen Teilen unseres
Landes inzwischen haben